now
september is hunger action month and our
parent company next our media group
along with feeding america the nation's
largest domestic hunger relief
organization working toward ending food
insecurity that's right but it's no
small job and they need your help now it
you can start by educating yourself
learning more about ways to end hunger
and exploring avenues where you can make
a difference julie unruh helps get us
started
how many bags ma'am
feeding america has been helping to
eradicate hunger for more than 40 years
a nationwide network with 200 food banks
and 60 thousand community partners coast
to coast but this giant hunger relief
organization providing 6.6 billion meals
this year alone comes from one great
idea and the man who made it happen it
all started in the late 60s with retired
businessman john van hengel from phoenix
one day he met a woman who was a mother
who was rummaging through garbage cans
in back of a grocery store she said that
grocery stores often throw away
perfectly good food wouldn't it be great
if there was a place where we could
store this food that is not bad it's not
wasted
in order for people to be able to access
it
and with that the concept of food
banking was born van hangel saw to it
making him the father of food banking
and the founder of feeding america
today more than ever with covet 19
stressors at work the need to feed our
neighbors continues to swell with one in
eight americans struggling with food
insecurity and one in six children so
next our media group has partnered with
feeding america and donated over two
million dollars over two years we're
using the scale of the company and the
power of nexstar to really try and make
an impact in an area of food insecurity
and hunger in america feeding america
says the pandemic has forced it to pivot
like the rest of society because of
massive disruptions in the supply chain
and volunteers were sent home to stay
safe
feeding america reminding us all access
to food is a basic right and communities
of color are being hardest hit
we need to decrease the stigma
that people facing hunger in this
country feel like they're accessing a
handout that is a right that they have
all month long we'll be sharing stories
about the efforts to eradicate hunger in
your community we invite you to watch
and help so neighbors where you live
don't go to bed hungry tonight reporting
from chicago i'm julie unruh
well if you want to help or if you're in
need of food assistance three square is
a member of feeding america yeah three
square in southern nevada's largest
hunger relief organization distributing
nearly 50 million meals always accepting
donations so that no one goes hungry